ni entrar en casas y tiendas de las castas superiores.
Así que me impresionó ver a los líderes de la comunidad
pronunciarse contra el sistema de castas intocables
y hablando de las ideas de Gandhi.
Así, inspirado por ellos, pensé, vamos a dar ejemplo
invitando a comer a estas personas
comida preparada y servida por intocables.
Fui a ver a personas de las castas inferiores, llamados intocables,
traté de convencerlos, pero era impensable para ellos.
Me dijeron: "No, no, no es posible, nunca sucedió".
Y les dije: "Miren a estos líderes,
son tan grandes que están en contra de la intocabilidad.
Vendrán, y si no viene nadie, podemos dar el ejemplo".
La gente pensaba que yo era demasiado ingenuo.
Finalmente, les convencí.
Mis amigos y yo tomamos las bicicletas e invitamos a los líderes políticos.
Me emocioné al ver que todos aceptaron venir.
Pensé, "Gran idea, podemos dar ejemplo.
Podemos cambiar la sociedad".
Llegó el día.
De los intocables, 3 mujeres y 2 hombres
aceptaron venir.
Recuerdo que llevaban su mejor ropa.
Trajeron utensilios nuevos.
Se habían duchado cientos de veces
porque para ellos todo esto era inaudito.
Llegó el momento del cambio.
Cocinaron. La comida ya estaba preparada.
Eran las 7.
Esperamos hasta las 8,
porque no es raro que los líderes se retrasen,
una hora más o menos.
Después de las 8, tomamos las bicicletas y fuimos a las casas de estos líderes,
solo para recordarles.
La esposa de uno de los líderes me dijo:
"Lo siento, tiene dolor de cabeza, tal vez no pueda ir".
Fui a otro líder y su esposa me dijo:
"Está bien, vete que seguro que acude".
Así que, pensé que la cena se llevaría a cabo,
aunque a menor escala.
Volví, era en el nuevo parque de Mahatma Gandhi.
Eran las 10.
Ninguno de los líderes apareció.
Me enojé.
Yo estaba de pie apoyado en la estatua de Mahatma Gandhi.
Estaba emocionalmente agotado, bastante agotado.
Así que me senté cerca de donde estaba la comida.
Me contuve.
Pero luego, cuando tomé el primer bocado, me eché a llorar.
Y de repente sentí una mano en mi hombro.
Era el toque maternal y curativo de una mujer intocable.
Me dijo: "Kailash, ¿por qué lloras?
Has hecho tu parte.
Has comido la comida cocinada por un intocable;
que recordemos, nunca había ocurrido antes".
Dijo: "Tú has ganado hoy".
Y, amigos, tenía razón.
Llegué a casa un poco después de la medianoche,
me sorprendió ver a algunos miembros ancianos de las castas superiores
sentados en el patio.
Vi a mi madre y a otras mujeres mayores llorando y suplicando a los ancianos
porque amenazaban con expulsar de su casta a todos mis familiares.
Y saben, ser expulsado de tu casta es el mayor castigo social imaginable.
De algún modo, acordaron castigarme solo a mí, y el castigo era la purificación.
Dijeron que tenía que ir a casi 1000 kilómetros de mi ciudad natal,
para bañarme en el sagrado río Ganges.
Después, tenía que organizar una fiesta para los sacerdotes, 101 sacerdotes,
lavar sus pies y beber esa agua.
Era una tontería absoluta
y me negué a aceptar el castigo.
¿Cómo me castigaron?
Me prohibieron entrar en la cocina y en el comedor de mi casa,
mis cubiertos se pusieron a parte.
Pero la noche cuando estaba tan furioso, porque querían convertirme en paria,
decidí convertir en paria a todo el sistema de castas.
(Aplausos)
Y esto era posible, pero lo primero era cambiar de nombre.
En India, la mayoría de apellidos son nombres de castas.
Así que decidí renunciar a mi nombre.
Luego, más tarde, me di un nuevo nombre: Satyarthi,
que significa, "El que busca la verdad".
(Aplausos)
Y ese fue el comienzo de mi ira transformadora.
Amigos, tal vez alguno de Uds. sepa
lo que hacía antes de convertirme en un activista pro derechos de los niños.
¿Alguien lo sabe?
No.
Era ingeniero, ingeniero eléctrico.
Luego me enteré cómo la energía
obtenida quemando carbón,
o en explosiones nucleares dentro de las cámaras,
o en furiosas corrientes de río,
o de los vientos fuertes,
se puede convertir en luz y la vida de millones de personas.
También aprendí cómo el tipo más incontrolado de energía
se puede aprovechar para el bien y mejorar la sociedad.
Así que volveré a la historia de cuando estaba preso en la cárcel.
Estaba muy feliz por sacar de la esclavitud a una docena de niños
y devolverlos a sus padres.
No puedo explicar mi alegría cuando libero a un niño.
Era tan feliz.
Pero mientras esperaba mi tren para volver a mi ciudad, Delhi,
vi docenas de niños que llegaban;
eran llevados por alguien.
Paré a estas personas.
Me quejé a la policía.
Entonces la policía, en vez de ayudarme,
me puso en un calabozo pequeño, diminuto, como si fuera un animal.
Y pasé una noche de furia
cuando una de las grandes ideas y de las más brillantes ha nacido.
Me di cuenta de que si por 10 niños que libero, 50 son esclavizados.
esto no se acaba.
Creía en el poder de los consumidores,
y diré que esta fue la primera campaña lanzada en el mundo,
para educar y sensibilizar a los consumidores
para crear una demanda de alfombras libres de trabajo infantil.
En Europa y EE.UU., lo hemos conseguido;
disminuyó el trabajo infantil en los países del sur de Asia en un 80 %.
(Aplausos)
Y no solo esas campañas del poder de los consumidores, las campañas del consumidor
se han extendido por otros países y en otras industrias
--quizás del chocolate, de la ropa, de los zapatos-- sino que fue más allá.
De mi ira a los 11 años
cuando me di cuenta de lo importante que es la educación para todos los niños,
se me ocurrió la idea de recoger libros usados y ayudar a los niños pobres.
Creé el banco de libros a los 11 años.
Pero no me detuve; más tarde, coparticipé en la creación de la campaña
de la sociedad civil más grande a nivel mundial,
que es la Campaña Mundial para la Educación
que ha ayudado a cambiar todo el pensamiento sobre la educación
desde el modelo de la caridad al de los derechos humanos,
y que ha ayudado claramente a reducir la tasa de niños no escolarizados
a la mitad en los últimos 15 años.
(Aplausos)
Mi ira a los 27 años,
de liberar a aquella niña que iba a ser vendida a un burdel,
me dio la idea
de encontrar una nueva estrategia para las redadas y el rescate,
para sacar a los niños de la esclavitud.
Y tengo la suerte y el orgullo de decir que no se trata de uno o 10 o 20,
sino de que mis compañeros y yo pudimos liberar físicamente 83 000 niños esclavos
y devolverlos a sus familias, a sus madres.
(Aplausos)
Sabía que necesitamos políticas a nivel global,
y organizamos marchas mundiales contra el trabajo infantil organizado
que también condujo a una nueva conferencia internacional
para la protección de los niños en los casos más desafortunados.
Y el resultado tangible fue que el número de niños trabajadores en todo el mundo
se redujo en un tercio en los últimos 15 años.
(Aplausos)
Así que, cada uno de los casos
empezó con la ira,
se convirtió en idea y acción.
Así que la ira, ¿luego qué sigue?
Una idea y...
(Audiencia) Acción.
Kailash Satyarthi: Ira, idea, acción. Lo que intenté hacer.
La ira es poder, la ira es energía,
y la ley natural es que la energía
nunca se crea ni desaparece, nunca puede ser destruida.
¿Entonces por qué la energía de la ira no puede traducirse y explotarse
para crear un mundo más justo, mejor, más hermoso e igual para todos?
La ira se encuentra dentro de cada uno de nosotros
y voy a compartir un secreto en unos segundos:
si nos limitamos a los caparazones estrechos de nuestro ego,
y a los círculos de egoísmo,
la ira se vuelve odio, violencia, venganza y destrucción.
Pero si podemos romper el círculo,
la misma ira puede convertirse en una fuerza tremenda.
Podemos romper el círculo con la ayuda de nuestra compasión intrínseca
y conectarnos con el mundo a través de la compasión para que el mundo sea mejor.
Esa misma ira puede convertirse en compasión.
Amigos tan queridos, hermanas y hermanos,
de nuevo, como Premio Nobel, les insto a que se enojen.
Les insto a que se enojen.
Ya que el más enojado entre nosotros
es el que puede transformar su ira en una idea y en acción.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)
Chris Anderson: Inspiró a muchos durante muchos años.
¿Quién o qué le han inspirado y por qué?
Kailash Satyarthi: Buena pregunta.
Chris, déjame decirte, y esa es la verdad,
cada vez que libero un niño
que perdió toda esperanza de regresar a su madre,
que veo la primera sonrisa de la libertad,
y la madre que había perdido toda esperanza que su hijo o hija
pudiera volver a sentarse en su regazo,
y se emocionan tanto
y veo la primera lágrima de alegría rodándoles por las mejillas,
vislumbro a Dios y esta es mi mayor inspiración.
Y soy tan afortunado de que no una vez sino, como he dicho antes, miles de veces,
he podido ser testigo de mi Dios en los rostros de los niños
y ellos son mi mayor inspiración.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)